Dominique Ambiel a préféré quitter ses
fonctions de Matignon plutôt que prévu
ce conseiller en communication le plus
proche collaborateur de Jean-Pierre
rafarin grand manitou des médias a
contribué pendant 2 ans à façonner
l'image du Premier ministre aujourd'hui
il est donc poussé de la scène politique
pour une affaire privée dans la nuit de
lundi à mardi Dominique interpellé dans
ce quartier parisien quelques minutes
auparavant les policiers ont mis en
place une surveillance de plusieurs
prostituées l'une d'entre elles roumaine
de 17 ans se trouve dans la voiture du
conseiller en communication selon
l'avocate de Dominique Ambiel il y a
méprise monsieur Ambiel a ouvert la
porte de sa de son véhicule alors qu'il
était 34h du matin il retourne à
Matignon pour chercher un dossier elle
se faisait agresser par une de ses
consœurs sous un abribus il a pris dans
sa voit voiture a avancé de 100 m et l'a
fait sortir immédiatement de son
véhicule fait troublant la jeune fille a
indiqué au policiers avoir rencontré à
plusieurs reprises Dominique Ambiel au
cours des dernières semaines notamment
dans un hôtel qu'il aurait payé avec sa
carte bleue lui ni tout en bloc je n'ai
jamais imaginé qu'on puisse aussi
facilement déshonorer quelqu'un aussi
aussi rapidement je vous le dis moi sur
l'honneur je n'ai jamais fréquenté de
prostitué de ma vie jamais je suis atéré
par des allégations aussi aussi
malveillante j'ai dit très exactement ce
qui s'est passé ce soir-là et il ne
s'agit en rien en rien de prostitution
placé en garde à vue pendant 4hur il a
été mis en examen pour relation sexuelle
sur mineur se livrant à la prostitution
et pour outrage car ce soir là il a
tenté de faire pression sur les
policiers il a d'abord contesté la
régularité du contrôle d'identité en
disant au policiers chargés du contrôle
vous savez qui je suis vous êtes sous
mes ordres vous n'avez pas le droit de
me contrôler et cetera donc cambiel
comparaîtra le 7 juin devant le tribunal
correctionnel de Paris il en court 3 ans
de prison et 45000 €
d'amende